until you love yourself and really have
self-acceptance along with
self-awareness you will not have nice
days you will have anxiety you will have
down days you will struggle here's
what's so [__] up and amazing about
this attention is the number one
asset hi my loves I cannot believe I'm
introducing you to this guest today the
one the only Gary Vayner Che Gary
welcome to leave room for the magic
podcast it is very surreal and fantastic
to have you here today I'm thrilled to
be doing it like guys well I cannot say
thank you enough for saying yes to my
audacious ass I met you at the shangra L
in Toronto your true hero of mine I've
been following you for a long time and
it's a pleasure to have you here happy
to be here thank you so much and and
this goes back to you always have to ask
like us bumping into each other when I
was having a business meeting in Toronto
you being in the hall working running up
to me I'm an incredible place in my
career where this is happening often
right I'm so flattered I'm humbled and
because I'm so flattered and humbled I
still want to leave room to do this in a
world where like and I know that I'm 5
minutes late so this will be 15 minutes
in a world where I'm I'm still behind on
like three of the biggest meetings I
could have for 15 minutes my admins
always ask me like why are we doing this
and they're coming from a good place and
this is I'm starting with this because I
want everybody to hear this for five
different
reasons it's because I love the game of
Entrepreneurship and people building
you're in a place now that I've been in
and I know me being on here changes the
course of this podcast I know in my mind
iously that you'll now be able to say
that I've been on the show and you will
book better guests and your journey is
now different that's humbling to me and
I need to keep and everybody listening
if you're lucky enough to be further
along in your journey you need to keep
having capacity to leave people deposits
of good this is a deposit of good and
listen for everybody who's listening and
there's been thousands of you that I
that ran up to me and said and I said no
I I'm sorry I just don't want to promise
or underd deliver or even worse I've
said yes but got lost in my inbox or you
know when I changed admins they lost
some you know like there's plenty of
times I've said yes to something as
audacious as your request and it didn't
happen and that sucks and I'm trying to
get better at that but more often than
not I've learned how to be humbly real
and say hey I just can't Carly I
apologize but good luck yes but I'm
pumped that when I said yes to you that
we're here now and I'm excited to do
this and I hope that people learn two
things from that little mini story that
we started with one always ask many of
you've seen me and you've been so sweet
you know how busy I am so you haven't
even asked let me decide if I can or
can't and you know like it's okay if you
ask nicely like you did yes nicely and
you know like I you know and one out of
every hundred times I say yes and one
out of every 10 times that I say yes it
gets fully done cuz it doesn't get lost
and here we are and then for everybody
else who's lucky enough to be a little
further along keep giving back I just
put out a video of me buying a lemonade
for 20 bucks because I grew up doing
lemonade
and somebody in 1985 stopped and gave me
10 bucks and I'll never forget it here I
am as a 47-year old man 40 years later
telling you a story of a biker I can
literally see him driving down tingly
Lane stopping and giving us 10 bucks to
fill up his lemonade his bike bottle and
it changed my life maybe maybe it got me
even more happy or addicted or believing
in my entrepreneurial Journey so I know
I'm talking a lot but I wanted to tell
that story because in the story of how
we even got here there's two massive
layers Le levers to pull one always ask
nicely and two always give back to the
game that got you
there wonderful well thank you I
actually my colleague who was sitting
there with me today actually recorded
the story of of the the synchronicity of
running into you and stuff like that so
that's going to be after your interview
so I hope people stay on and listen to
that because it's a a fun magical one
for me and uh and it's magical to have
you there here today and actually I'd
love to start with that question because
one of the things that really struck me
is somebody you know who's flying around
doing all these business meetings
running multiple companies you're very
present with everybody that you come
across cuz I witnessed you uh
interacting with a colleague of mine as
we were leaving a conference how do you
develop you know what how do you get
prepared at the beginning of the day to
develop that kind of presence that you
can have that attention with people I
don't know if it's a beginning of the
day thing I think it's a you know every
second of the day thing which is you
know I'm aware that my communication
style doesn't necessarily represent
humility you know I speak with heavy
conviction I'm competitive you know I'm
uh ambitious these are all things that
you know may elude if you're not paying
close attention and I don't expect
anyone to play close attention to me
everyone's busy they don't need to be
worried about me but yeah the hardest
thing to see for everybody who consumes
me on the internet is the humility right
like Julian and I Julian's filming me
right now right we were at the airport
in uh Utah uh this weekend actually
Saturday and we're we had like a few
minutes to talk in the airport and we're
kind of talking about he brought up like
we something wild happened actually and
like the way I handled it I'm proud of
it was it was a very weird sitch and I
would say it was acceptable if not
expected for me to handle it differently
and I handled it with Grace calmness
empathy for the person that made the
massive mistake and and we had this nice
moment we were walking and he kind of
talked about some of his friends in his
world who aren't into entrepreneurship
don't really know me outside of like you
know I'm pretty omnipresent at this
point if you have a so if you're into
social media you seen me and you know
they're they're they're surprised and
intrigued by the things he says he
others on my team they know me cuz they
see me behind the scenes you got to see
a little bit of that by Just Happening
to be out in the wild where I was like
in the wild do you know what I mean yes
yeah absolutely but that was a micro
moment we were 5 Seconds you could have
gotten a good version of someone these
people really know me and I think the
answer to your question is humility how
why am I present because I don't think
I'm better than you when you and I
interact I like that you know I think I
understand why people want to interact
with me yeah but that that even humbles
me more yeah you know and so I think
humility is imperative I think genuine
curiosity I'm curious so I like meeting
people I know I like to know their story
and look I think I have a genuine love
for people so it's easier for me to be
present because I like the human on the
other side I default into optimism I
don't approach people with cynicism I
don't think that I they need to earn my
trust I give it to them on day one I'm
openhearted I'm pure of I'm full of love
for my fellow humans until proven
otherwise and even when proven otherwise
I deploy compassion and sympathy for
them trying to hurt or do wrong and so
that emotional framework leads to being
intent and and and really locked in with
people well I know you've talked a lot
online about those are skill sets that
your parents and especially your mom has
given you over the time is that a muscle
you've built over your lifetime like
between yes 18 and 47 yeah and I would
say even earlier I think a lot about
high school I it's it's kind of crazy
how I navigated High School I was 4'11
my freshman year of high school
whicho you know you know when you know
and I looked 11 so now I'm 14 going into
high school I look 1112 on a good day
I'm 411 if you don't think senior
guys picked out you know their the easy
Target and I think back to the first
months of freshman year high school
recently and I was like man I was and
maybe this is happening cuz my
daughter's gotone into high school now
and I'm seeing the same in her like I
was just able to navigate it emotionally
like no teasing no making fun of no
bullying no pushing no physical or
emotional or verbal conflict penetrated
my
self-esteem so so I was locked in fairly
early and then because of that because I
was good now I had the capacity to bring
good so Not only was I dealing with it I
was the one who was the hand around the
shoulder for my fellow classmates who
weren't able to deal with it so not only
did I probably get picked on and razed
and beat up a little bit more than the
rest of the gang cuz I was of the size
and like and I'm also loud in who I am
to begin with so I was an easy target I
was able to First convert any of that
negative energy to positive energy
pretty quickly because even at 14 I had
enough Charisma to flip even the
toughest bully that was a junior but
second I was there for my homies right I
was there for classmates I just met who
just like freshman year High School in
1990 in New Jersey yeah was let's put it
this way Politically Incorrect and so
you know I think um I think it's always
been there but it is a muscle that I've
worked on day and day out day in and day
out and I continue to work on it daily I
think I think being the bigger person
yeah is something I practice every day
that's wonderful but I'm going to shift
gears here a little bit Gary um one of
the questions I I had for you coming
into this you've talked online about um
your your intuition being like the brain
in your stomach and I think a lot of
business people talk about like the
Tactical stuffs um and people touch on
the intuitive pieces of it but if I
think about you know one of my questions
for you is how do you navigate your gut
intuition do you have practical tools
and checks against that gut intuition of
course the results yeah but I'm not
scared but I'm not scared of losing
right why am I so good at intuition
quote unquote because I don't fear being
wrong see what see what's happening
there I love how you reacted got it
there's two things going on it's not
that I'm more intuitive than everyone
it's that I'm willing to risk it on my
intuition because if I'm wrong two
things happened I lost than I
learned and I get ridiculed or judged
but I don't care right and I don't care
because I'm audacious I don't care
because I'm empathetic that one's
judgment on my business decision if I
failed is no different than me being
frustrated with the New York Jets
they're allowed right they're
allowed yeah is there a gap between you
acting on your Intuition or do you do
you typically at this stage just kind of
flow with it have have you ever had it I
guess conversely have you ever had a
time where you went against your
intuition and kind of learned from that
as well of course you know it's not very
clear to me like you know my brain moves
pretty fast I'm was trying to think of a
quick good example for you but like yeah
of course normally when I'm being overly
hopeful I'm I'm uncomfortably optimistic
and I think I've had to become more and
more practically optimistic through the
years I'm very good at like taking the
Stray Dog home only to then get bit and
have a disease I'm like like I always
used to tell my girlfriends girls that
were my friends that weren't my
girlfriends I used to always in college
and high school and post College tell
them that like oh thank God I'm not a
girl I would have only dated Bad Boys
cuz I have I love a good fixing project
like I find them i' literally find the
most completely broken dude and like try
to fix him you know what I mean that
cliche like I've definitely done a poor
job hiring through the years because I'm
doing a form of Charity more than I'm
doing a form of running business these
are things I've had to get better at
yeah I've heard you talk about your
superpower being empathy before and and
I think a lot of empathetic people fall
into that pattern of fixing and thinking
they can do more with somebody
especially in a relationship sense they
can't 100% And that's okay too like I
don't mind all those losses I would have
do I do it again you gave somebody a try
you you went for optimism you went for
love you went for Hope but you know
there's consequences to making bad
decisions and if you're a little I think
I'm better at
recognizing whom to make those jumps
with I don't and I think there's a level
of humility that wasn't in that I felt
so over the top emotionally strong that
there was probably a part of me that
thought I could fix anyone and I think
now I'm learning like at what cost and
to and now I look at it as to the cost
of whom big thing that's happening in my
career is I'm now worried about the top
20% of my
organization not getting the financial
emotional
and all the other value they can get
from me and my companies because I'm
spending too much time enabling and
entitling the bottom
20% and that's been a new reconciling
that I have to do in my own body yeah um
similar along similar lines to that I
know you've got this big life goal of
oning the Jets I mean it's in your bio I
think there's a lot of talk about
manifesting online but this this podcast
tries to bridge the spiritual and the
Practical so when you're trying to make
decisions if that's a big life goal of
yours how do you make decisions the
short-term decisions to ensure you're
staying on track towards that Big Goal I
mean the big goal is complicated I think
a lot of times if somebody doesn't know
me especially if they have like let's
say maybe even a cynical view it's like
GH another guy trying to be a
billionaire and buy the Jets but this is
like if you go to my Instagram the first
post I have pinned goes very deep into
why this has been with me since I was
seven eight years old and good one yeah
and I think honestly even when you ask
this question probably the reason I just
answered that is I don't really focus on
that I don't really focus that today was
another stepping stone to buying the
Jets I focus on today is another day I'd
like to be happy and deliver on my
responsibilities and I'm aware that I
have this big goal in the background I
try to aim big and I try to do big
things and I try to build but I'm not
crippled by the literal interpretation I
think a lot of the theme of this talk is
I focus on the gray more than the black
and white yeah and I think you've
referenced it multiple times it makes me
feel in different ways TCT ICS of this
like so it makes me feel like you see
me I'm playing in the gray you know I'm
playing in the gray and I think the gray
is where the magic is the black and
white is obvious like again like you
said I can literally go Google or
YouTube how to blank blank blank and
know how to do everything on Earth
literally for
free how to is nothing I know how to get
more muscles like get in the gym tear up
my muscles put [__] protein in it as
much as possible quickly after and you
know but even though I want some more
muscles and I've started to get a little
bit of a chest cuz I'm doing more and
more push-ups I don't do it thus I don't
have it right and so like people know
how to do things I mean almost
everything people ask me in business
they know how to do because they can
Google it they don't know how to get
themselves to do it and that's why I'm
so passionate about mindset and
gratitude and empathy and patience it's
why I created V friends to create these
characters that embody I want the world
to fall in love with patient Panda
because then patience will be cooler I
want the world to fall in love with
resilient Red Devil because I think
resilience is not being championed
enough right now I think we're over
coddling too much in certain situations
which is actually creating
entitlement and insecurity you can't
like if you over coddle your children
and the world it will lead to
entitlement and
insecurity yeah and so you got to find
the balance meanwhile comforting and
being there for people is amazing so how
do we find a balance that's why the
balance NE it's been very cool to see
your messaging and I'll direct people if
they're not familiar with your your
messaging and and everything but thank
you for champing self- awareness and
these great emotional spectrum that we
all have and navigate and thank you so
much for your time and being here today
I really appreciate the Magic's in the
gray you heard it from Gary V you're
being very sweet cuz you're being dead
on time and I'm going to be sweet and
return and say something
else which is I hope for everybody
that's listening let me throw out a
couple themes we didn't get to touch on
but our kissing cousins of everything we
just talked about yeah until you love
yourself and really have self-acceptance
along with self-awareness yeah until
that happens you will not have nice days
you will have anxiety you will have down
days you will
struggle here's what's so [__] up and
amazing about this
you get to
decide life is gray life is beauty is in
the eye of the beholder literally for
everyone who's listening and I can like
feel like somebody who's never heard of
me right now listening crying I can feel
it car that's how intense this is why I
want to stay based on this momentum
until you love yourself nothing will
happen and good news you're allowed to
love yourself cuz you're the judge and
the jury
yeah and you have to get out of you have
to get out of blame To Love Yourself you
blaming your parents for [__] is
allowing you to have a package a
container to continue to not love
yourself we must become more emotionally
accountable we are capable you are
capable to get free meditation you are
capable to get free exercise AKA like
push-ups in your room walking on a hill
you are there's unlimited you are free
to recognize that you're hanging around
people that are negative and you can
start limiting that time and you can go
to the person that's most positive in
your office and be like hey Carly I want
to be your friend can I take you out for
lunch today you are you are in control
not everybody can afford therapy but for
those that can you car do you know most
people would rather buy a Chanel bag or
a
Porsche to cover up their hurt instead
of spend those dollars on
therapy yeah everyone then good it's so
tied with self-awareness because
potentially they don't have the
self-awareness to realize that's what
they're trying to know what do you think
correct but what do you think I'm doing
here ready very simple this is a simple
game you don't have to be an emotional
intelligence genius are you happy more
times when you wake up than you are not
mhm the end you don't need to be the how
often are you happy I wake up
happy 90% of the time 5% 8% indifferent
and 2% anxious that is off the charts
now num that is I'm not even asking for
people to do that I got the luck of the
draw I did a lot of work there's a lot
that went into me being here at 47 my
question is where are you right Julian
what's your answer happy indifferent
anxious not great Go real talk no
[__] 75% happy 20% indifferent
whatever the rest is 5% that's
incredible that makes me look at Julian
and I know him enough to be like fits in
the pocket how about you Carly real talk
no [__] vulnerable go with me real
talk right now I'm 50/50 great I'm not a
bit of a roller coaster I'm feeling in
transition in a weird stage of my life
what you just did for everyone is
everything yeah you have an audience
that looks up to you likes you many of
the people listening whether you have
nine listeners or 900 look up to you and
for them to hear that 50% of the time
that you wake up you're
me yeah for me this is where if we were
best friends you would be 80 90 I'll
tell you why would have convinced you
through the years of being together or
over one important dinner that not
knowing where you're going is not
bad it's actually
cool yeah like what nobody really knows
where they're going I'm a tree may fall
on my head today I didn't know that was
going to
happen like nobody knows being
comfortable with not knowing where the
next turn of the roller coaster is
that's I have nothing but headaches I I
had a lot of bad things happen today
already it's 3:24 p.m. I mean real
things got to fire a partner in one
business like somebody's sick like
personal like there's I've had a rough
day by everyone's standards besides the
5% of people that are like me right it's
okay
yeah well I've seen the Reps you put in
I I go back off and I'm 33 right now and
it's a very Stark difference from my 20s
where I feel like I knew the next step
if I was transitioning I kind of knew
what was coming next and this has been a
an interesting one where I feel the
transition but I don't know the next and
that's the were the magic were you a
good student yes makes all the sense in
the world
yeah everything I just heard is you knew
the system you knew how to get the a
there's a reason I got FS I don't give a
[__] about the system the system is the
problem yeah you not knowing what's next
is the best thing that happened to you
it's time for you to let go and know
that you're not in control at all
right fun Carl you're liter you're
literally literally not in control yeah
maybe this podcast is the changing
moment of your
career yeah you didn't you didn't
strategically decide to sit in that
[__] restaurant Hotel in Toronto
promise it wasn't I'm going to sit here
because Gary B is in town and he's going
to walk through here no I had no idea
correct that's life that's real life
yeah cool love you see you very neat
thank you so much G take
[Music]
care